schools are opening this week with a
steady focus on the coronavirus threat
this morning the total number of
reported coveted cases in the u.s is
approaching
6 million here in new york a spike in
cases has forced
another university to go online only as
dr john lapook
reports the students are not happy about
that
tell me why suny oneonta
has a hundred and five cases didn't tell
us
and we had to find out on the news just
one week after suny oneonta welcomed
students back to campus
institutions do not care about their
students
a spike in on-campus coronavirus cases
is forcing the new york state university
to shut down
for at least two weeks it didn't feel
like
they were doing their best and ensuring
our safety in the first place
senior malacca says she and her
classmates were frustrated by what she
says
is the school's lack of testing
resources and transparency
if they're going to open up the schools
then they're responsible for
you know communicating with us whether
we're in danger or not of the virus
colleges have not followed basic public
health rules they haven't done
entry testing they haven't done
quarantining dr ashi
shah and other public health officials
are urging students already on campus to
stay there
to prevent the spread of the virus if we
were able to test
everybody on campus twice a week that
would make it dramatically safer to be
on campus
across the country colleges are
struggling to contain clusters of covet
outbreaks
in texas baylor university ordered 55
students
21 of them positive to reside in place
on two floors of a dorm
one university of alabama campus has
reported more than a thousand positive
cases since classes began two weeks ago
and cases at arizona state university
nearly tripled
reaching 480 cases in just three days
we can get colleges and universities
open safely this fall
but only if we're willing to follow the
public health guidance
and the protocols
new york governor andrew cuomo is
deploying a covet swat team to suny
oneonta
to help contain the outbreak meanwhile
the head of the fda told the financial
times over the weekend
he is willing to consider fast tracking
a future covid vaccine
making it available to the public before
the end of the final trials
gail john that's a little frightening
can you fast track and still maintain
safety
well i'm going to be talking to the
commissioner this morning and so we'll
have more news about that later on the
evening
cbs evening news with nora o'donnell and
again tomorrow if you'll have me
we will always have you jama puke thank
you very much